abone ol
bu tarihinden önce bir bana söyle
deseydi ki Binlerce yüz binlerce nerede
kuruluşu ki bunların içerisinde Time
dergisi kızlar gelip magazine var en
azından fox'a Liseye kadar binlerce o
günlerde ulusal Ayrıca sosyal medya
hesabından Senin adın ne
ne Allah'ı ne de bir hal olmak 27 Kasım
tarihinde çok sıradan bir şekilde görev
yapıyorum Ben bir yazılım şekilde
hayatım yazılım geliştirerek kazandım
evvel o gün de tıpkı diğer ürünler gibi
masalda yazalım geliştirdim
arkadaşlarımla beraber uygulamalı
üzerine tartıştık akşam 6.00 gibi
ofisten ayrılıyor niyetlendiğini çarpım
toplarken altıda bir arkadaşım bana
geldi yanıma geldi ve dedi ki İki sayı
yakaladım Çünkü kaldım ofisteki herkesin
makinasında yönetici hesabı için şifre
atladık senin makyaj atmamız gerekiyor
Ben Hayırdır niye benim ki bir
arkadaşımın hesabına yapamadığı için
bu internet aramaya başlamışlar
hesabımızı kurtarabilir sizlere formunda
form Kendisi de söylüyor abi yedi
girmişler Eğer yönetici olarak bir
hesaba girip şifresiz olarak ince
tıklarsanız hata alıyorsunuz ancak
ikincisinde giriş yapabiliyorsunuz
şifresiz olarak istediğiniz Bakın bu da
[Müzik]
ne yapmak istediğim şey standart olarak
Eğer sosyal medya izin kullanmak yani
aldığımız gelmiyor olabilir yavru
Fazlada olabilir o zaman Ne yapıyorsunuz
o zaman yapacağınız tek şey Belki de şu
anda onları size ulaşmasını sağlamak
aynı şey aslında düşünceler 9.00 9.30
gibi yeni o
319 diye başlayan Aslında şunu
söylüyorum Burada çok büyük bir açık var
bunu bunun farkında mısın bunu yaptıktan
sonra masaya koydum evet çocuğum devam
ettim o
bu ve Ekledin mi inanılmaz ya herkes
işte Türkiye Kız Eğer şey vurmuş vesaire
derken en büyük mavi hesaplardan başladı
özellikle sorumluluk o
O ev bugün Ağrı kazanmaya başladı Hatta
be bu dava ederse destekleyecekler
insanlardan yapmaya başladım hayatımda
hiç yabancı değil de vardı ve ben ne
yapacağımı bilmiyorum ki
her şey çok garip bir şey arkadaşlar
12 Binlerce yıl öncesinde bir mesleğe
ait etik kurallarına dinlendi var
Hipokrat yemini bir mesleğe ait mesleki
etik kuralları bulunduğu dâhiyane
harikulade değil Belki bunun gibi birçok
meslek birçok farklı belgede var etik
kavramını ele Ahlak kavramı da çok
evrenseldir yani toplulukları ve
kültürel ahlaki değerlere göre o
ben Ahmet kavramları derinlemesine
inceler Hadise düşünür üzerine bilimsel
çalışmalarla destekleyen bunu evrensel
bir noktaya ulaşmıştır dediğimiz
kaldırımın mesleğimize nasıl enjekte
edeceğiz nasıl hayatımızın bir parçası
haline getireceğiz
Biz bunu cevaplamadan önce su soruya
cevap vermemiz gerekiyor Eğer bu zamanda
iş görüşmelerine gidiyorum bu iş
görüşmelerinde Şu soruyu soruyorum Siz
bir meslek Erdal bildiğiniz al yardımcı
olabilirsiniz olabilirsiniz ortak olan
Doktorunuz kim olursanız bunun
mesleğinizin en iyileri düşün Onlar
sizin yüzünüzden isminde en iyiler Peki
bu iyi olmalarını sağlayan o özellikle
nedir bu özelliği yazabilir misin diye
soruyor bunu yazmak Eğer ciddi
Biz birbirimiz gereken bir soru hepsini
yapıyor musunuz zaten Muhtemelen vermemi
istiyorsunuz size gidiyor olacaktım yani
olmadığını karşında sonra yapmak için o
bu ilkeler sizin şehriye bilecek
imkanınız varken etik kurallarını
çevirebilecek imkanımız varken şeyin
etmeyecek olan şey gideceğiz
bu interaz çok önemli bir yardımcı
oluyor bu da otobanda sınır özellikle
İstanbul'da trafikteyken etik
değerlerimiz eğitimlerinizi sorgulayacak
o zaman biliyorsunuz insanın
hareketlerine bakıp geçiyorsun
yapıyorsunuz özellikle Eğer yoksa
yandaki Gitmeyeceğim diye kendimize ait
bir program varsa yapma ya
bu toplayıp yönetim izle bunun ciddi
anlamda tartışması
bu insanlar bizi biz yapan şeylerin
başında geliyor ki biz ilkelerimizi
nasıl İnceğiz nasıl sahip çıkacağız
o Kargo'nun ters soğuk Stadı'nda çok
güzel bir söz var
bu ortam okumak köpürür
ne yaptın robux istiyo su şöyle hali bir
adet göstermiş sıradan olmak WhatsApp
olmak vatsaplık işlemiş edeceğiz ev
değildir durumlardan biridir Eğer ki
eğer başarısız olursanız o zaman
yaptığınız hataları gözler geçirmek için
bir fırsatınız olur kendi zor hafif
olarak değerlendirirseniz hatalarınızdan
ders çıkarmış şansımız olur ancak
sıradan olursanız whatsapi çıkartırsanız
diğerleri gibi bir Konfor de mutlu mesut
yaşarsınız hiçbir şeyin farkında olmadan
her zaman her şey o
bu değiştirdiğinizde başka bir takıma
geçtiğinizde yeni bir teknoloji öğrenmek
zorunda kaldığımız ha dünyanın bambaşka
bir noktaya gittiğini görüp ne kadar
aciz kaldığımızı görüşürüz
ve bu hu ben seneler önce yazıları 21
arkadaşlarından beraber çalışırken
onların arasından geçer karşılıklı öyle
geçiyorduk ve arkadaşım gördük
Arkadaşlar bu arada bakıyorum uzun
dikkatli dikkatli ol
Bu proje yada eksik Test olarak var onu
iyi görünecek seni sevebiliyorum
ben seni seviyorum seviyorum O esir tek
sonra ben de uzun TL aldım Yani temiz
geliştirme dini görevler oldu e-okuldaki
yani ben tamamlandı oyuncusu acayip
yapacağım diye düşünüyorum o
ya bugünler Karadeniz'de sıçrama
yapabilmek için gereken en önemli şey
bize veriyor zamanı Bir buçuk sene
boyunca dünyada çok az insan kullandığı
ve benden sonrada Muhtemelen dünyada
kimsenin kullanmadığı sonra acayip çok
sorunlu bir geliyoruz yine O biraz o
kadar dünyada tek da o
o Çünkü burada önemli olan değer sıfır
her çalışan kendi kararıyla kendisi
falan çıkmak zorundadır bu kadar biz
şirketimiz bize verebilmemiz değil anne
Babamız bizi elimizden tutup bizi iyi
yapmak zorunda olan kişi yaşayacak
şirketimiz değil sadece pis yani Eğer
kitaplarımızda onu okumak zorunda olan
biz Eğer teknoloji ölmesi gerekiyor
olması gerekiyor Şu an
Evet şimdi borcunu sonra şunu
sorabilirsiniz Bir saniye yani genel
başkanlığı da yapmıştır ve bu kadar
büyük bir açığı sorunsuzca kusursuzca
açıklamıştı biraz doğru Payı yok mu yani
bakınca her şu an size ön sonsuz
söylemem gerekiyor Bu acı bir Xero değil
mi
[Müzik]
ve Yüzlerce belki binlerce hesabını
arkadaşlar olabilirler bazen yapmanız
gereken şeydir Eğer ki bir yangın Siz
hemen çıktıysa gelme şansımız oluyor
üzerine battaniye atarsınız yağlı
çıkarsanız o da o da o